احتفال برشلونه يتحول الى حاله ذعر ولا
بورتي يؤكد تمسكه باعاده ميسي وقنابل
الدخان توقف مباراه هولنديه هذه الاخبار
وغيرها نقول لكم عبر قناه العربيه رياضه
حياكم الله
خلال احتفال لاعبي وافراده برشلونه بلقب
التاسع عشر كبطل للدوري الاسباني تحول
الاحتفال الى حاله ذحر واقتحم عدد من
جماهير الغريم التاريخي اسبانيول بهدف
الاعتداء على لاعبي برشلونه في ظل عداوه
تاريخيه تجمع الفريقين المنتميين لمدينه
برشلونه ومع دخول الجماهير وتوجههم لموقع
رقص اللاعبين بدا اللاعبون بالركض نحو نفق
غرف الملابس واسرعوا بالخروج من الملعب
بينما انتشر رجال الامن واستطاعت قوات
الامن السيطره على الوضع ولم يتعرض اي من
لاعبي برشلونه للاعتداء
ونبقى في برشلونه حيث اكد اخوانلا بورتو
رئيس النادي انه سيبذل قصار جهده لاعاده
نجم الاسطول الارجنتيني هذا الصيف واشار
له بورصه الى انه تحدث مع ميسي لمحاوله
استعاده العلاقه بينهما التي تضررت عندما
غادرت كامب نو العام 2021 اراد ميسي
البقاء في برشلونه لكن النادي لم يتمكن من
الاحتفاظ به بسبب ديونه التي زادت عن
ملياريون
توقفت مباراه وضيفي اياكس في الدوري
الهولندي بعدما تم القاء قنابل الدخان على
ارض الملعب مرتين وتوقفت المباراه اولا
بعد سبع دقائق حينما تم القاء قنابل
الدخان على ارض الملعب من جماهير
وتم استئناف اللعب بعد خمسه عشره دقيقه
قبل ان يتوقف مجددا عقب دقيقتين فقط حيث
تم القاء المزيد من قنابل الدخان ليؤدي
ذلك الى انهاء المباراه مبكرا
احتفل الوسط الكروي في العاصمه اليابانيه
طوكيو بعيد ميلاد الدوري المحلي لكره
القدم الذي بلغ 30 عاما ولتكريم افضل من
ساهم في تشكيل هذه الرياضه على مدار
العقود الثلاثه الماضيه اشاركت اليابان في
كل نهائيات كاس العالم منذ تشكيل الدوري
المحترف في العام 93 وكانت دوري الياباني
مرادفا لصعود اليابان في كره القدم
العالميه ويمكن القول انه من اكثر القصص
شهره في كره القدم الاسيويه خلال ثلاثين
عاما الماضيه
[موسيقى]